I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the shiboshibonomi which
allows you to ring the juice out of
literally anything it was eaten by
smoothie the strongest of big mom's
daughters now for strength you can drain
the liquid out of a person leaving them
dangerously dehydrated and all the
liquid you gather can also be used to
send Wicked flying slash 12 out of 25
points you can also ring harmful
substances like poison out of your body
so 8 coins in terms of Defense in terms
of special abilities you can use any
liquid you take from others to transform
yourself into a giant plus the juice you
extract makes a young drink so 18 points
here however it's not exactly practical
for everyday use unless you work at a
juice bar so a sour five points for that
however on the upside it doesn't have
any real weaknesses either which brings
its total to a tasteless 43 points and
sadly just out of the top three four
Goods